[Music]
foreign
because there was less money such stuff
um
actually helped me because uh I was kind
of lagging behind so during that time at
home I was able to catch up and now I'm
good so
we found strong Commerce where is
[Music]
um
this is how many children and young
people worldwide experienced the
pandemic their schools were closed often
their parents lost their jobs
but now around the world classes are
taking place in person again welcome to
the covid-19 special in this show we
take a closer look at what it's like for
students and teachers to be together in
classrooms again we head to Germany
Colombia Nigeria and Uganda
in more than eight months since Ugandan
schools fully reopened but teachers
still aren't happy with their pupils
progress
most of the children do not again pick
anything completely
even those who understand who even
outright their names
they could not again write their names
they could find again everything was
very new to them
so we started like letter by letter
again teaching them
others hidden even a hundred pencil with
them others others even for whatever now
to handle persons
in March 2020
Uganda announced the full closure of
schools to manage the spread of covet
19. milka and ambabazi thought it would
last a week or two but it dragged on for
22 months becoming the world's longest
School closure
never even bothered me that I'll spend
like one month or one year at home so I
took a few books to revise
but unfortunately
time went on
never telling us that we have to go back
to school so I was like
what so now what's the next thing I'm
gonna do
milk
is finally back in school but her grades
have dropped
it affected me my performance in Sydney
airport I made minute to take a
combination that I wanted I wanted to do
head at his history a con and Divinity
stock ICT stock submar but since I never
performed like the way I expected it
made me it caused me to take a
combination that wasn't my expectation
many students are struggling to catch up
now that they're back at school teachers
say that it's even harder for those who
had started working during the two-year
school break
they were always thinking of their
businesses aside some of them we
discover they have stores chapati stores
yeah they have been attending to
matokeo uh stores are getting it so they
could get some money it has been a
challenge you find that even some girls
are not concentrating they engage in
coupling expecting something from the
boys because they have been used to
getting some money it's hard to
concentrate in class now because my mind
is more exposed to many things then I
didn't know a lot of things because I
had less time focus on the outside world
I had only my books and then me and then
school but then after then in coffee
they were exposed to working instead of
being here I would be working and making
my own money because most of most of my
friends are there outside making good
money and faster back again in school
the Uganda National examinations board
reports that students have performed
poorly since the pandemic numeracy or
the ability to do basic math has fallen
by over 13 percent and more pupils have
also dropped out of score often due to
covert induced poverty and teenage
pregnancies
thousand adolescent girls were reported
to have been pregnant during the covet
period meaning that there was one
thousand girls on daily basis getting
pregnant surely that's a disaster for
our country and it is going to have a
vicious cycle because you will not have
a skilled labor you will not have a very
productive labor you will have a a
population that's it that is largely
byzantry
the UN reports that even before the
pandemic nearly 60 percent of the
world's ten-year-olds could not read and
understand a simple text
covid-19 has now deepened that crisis
especially in sub-Saharan Africa
[Music]
schools in Nigeria were also closed for
months due to the coronavirus pandemic
and here too the authorities but also
International organizations and
companies have tried to reduce the
resulting educational deficits by
developing digital learning models but
not everyone was able to benefit from it
foreign
[Music]
are preparing for the new school year
both sisters topped their classes last
year and are determined to do that again
this semester
they're taking lessons on a digital
platform called the Nigeria learning
passport
now I'm studying biology I'm floating
pollution
types of pollution
on the Nigeria learning passport
preschool to Secondary School pupils can
register to take video lessons on demand
I like studying with the Nigeria
learning passport because it makes me
understand there is no noise I can
barcode it I can pause it so that I can
jot it down and I and I can understand
this very
Nigeria recently joined 20 other
countries to adopt the learning passport
it's a tool that was developed by UNICEF
and Microsoft to help students continue
learning in spite of academic
disruptions
the learning passport actually
initiative started about two three years
ago in Afghanistan in the emergency
contacts environment but the deployment
deployment actually was
accelerated with the covid-19 pandemic
that struck the the world
it's the first day of school
money class
good morning sit down
zainab's teacher introduced her and
other classmates to the Nigeria learning
passport
now she wants to see if the students
actually used it
how many of all use the learning
passport to study at all apart from
creating the profile
don't be shy stand up
zynab is one of just four pupils others
say their parents can't afford data
smartphones or tablets so they can't
learn online
almost half of Nigerians have no
internet access the government is
working to make the learning passport
available offline but expects to reach
just 3 million of the country's 20
million children by Year's End
back at home zainab and amarat are doing
their afternoon chores they don't know
how much longer their parents can
continue to buy data for their online
lessons
but they plan to use every opportunity
to fulfill their dreams
I need to be educated because I want to
become a medical doctor I want to study
medicine so I'm without education
there's nothing I want to achieve all
this my all my goals without me not
being educated
while pupils like zainab and amarat are
lucky to have access to the learning
passport millions of other children in
Nigeria may never get the chance to use
it
digital learning was also widespread on
other continents during the pandemic
such as Latin America
but in Colombia it became clear that
there was also a downside and the
inequality between rich and poor was
also brought into stark contrast
Colombia's constitutional Court says
that many young people did not receive
the education they needed during the
lockdowns
Diana trebino is a sixth grade student
at a public school in Colombia
she completed the fourth and fifth
grades at home using Whatsapp but she
feels that she didn't learn enough
since the pandemic it's more difficult
to keep up at school in fifth grade I
understood some things but not
everything
I felt anxious I thought what if they
ask me stuff and I don't know anything
that they might be angry with me
I help improve her academic performance
Diana is attending extra lessons outside
of school
she says she's happy to sacrifice her
free time because it's helping her to
catch up at school
my reading comprehension has improved I
wasn't reading well before I also enjoy
reading and writing much more than I
used to I didn't used to be into reading
much
[Music]
the extra lessons were organized by
teachers like Fabian Velasco the classes
help him to understand the difficulties
that his students are facing so that he
knows how he can best support them
he is well aware that the pandemic
created bigger challenges for public
school students
many of the children had connectivity
issues their families just didn't have
enough phones and laptops it was all
very limited
schools and other educational
institutions tried to find Solutions but
it wasn't easy
there were families with two or three
children but only one working device
as a result the Gap in education
standards between private and public
schools grew during the pandemic
experts say the inequality was already
there before covid but the pandemic has
exacerbated the problems
thousands and thousands of children and
young people in Colombia had the right
to education denied during the pandemic
two out of every three young people in
public schools in Colombia did not have
a computer
so for a good part of the last two years
those students were unable to continue
their education
many feel they now need to work harder
to catch up with students at private
schools Maria Juliana is also attending
extracurricular classes
the pandemic has definitely made things
more difficult in eighth grade Sciences
like chemistry and physics became
individual subjects but that was when
everything went online so I missed out
on all the basics of these subjects now
in 10th Grade the material where
learning is much more complex but I feel
like I don't have the basics
Maria Juliana says academic challenges
aren't the only problem she's noticed
that many of her classmates are now more
anxious and insecure than they were
before the pandemic
yes it's something you notice and I
think we sometimes just ignore it maybe
because we think they're exaggerating or
that these mental health issues are
considered trendy
but these are problems that are
affecting a lot of students right now
mainly because they spent the entire
pandemic glued to an electronic device
and that increased their problems
the school has actually decided to limit
the use of cell phones and tablets
assignments are now written by hand
instead the school is also urging
students to ask for psychological help
if they need it
many of the students are experiencing
problems they've been exposed to screens
for two years without limitations many
are now addicted to devices
they were also exposed to pornography
that invaded their homes Without Limits
or controls
when they were at school we regulated
everything but at home that was
impossible
schools in Colombia are doing all they
can to give back to their students the
Lost Years it's a daily effort that
requires a major commitment not just
from the teachers but also from the
students
worldwide children are back in the
classroom in the northern hemisphere
autumn and winter are approaching many
fear a new wave of coronavirus
infections what are schools doing to
prepare for that what are their biggest
concerns
in Germany worries about another
covid-19 outbreak are compounded by the
current energy crisis
the new school year began all quite
normally without masks or Cova tests a
huge relief for students at the Paola
first school in the southwestern city of
Freiburg
it caters for children from elementary
school to University entrance age
still School director gerd Pollock is
concerned about the weeks ahead
experts say the infection numbers could
rise considerably this fall
the government says it's well prepared
but get Pollock isn't convinced
we're not getting any details on what
preparations have been made as a school
we're pretty uninformed as far as covert
regulations for the fall are concerned
we don't know what measures are to be
taken if there's a new wave of
infections we will probably be told what
to do at the last minute just like last
fall but then still have to carry
everything out very carefully which
means as a school we'll have to act very
fast
foreign
in other words things would be very
stressful again in schools
teachers associations are calling for a
clear action plan
but so far all that's been said is that
measures in schools could be tightened
up if the situation requires it
the government wants to remain flexible
most of the children aren't bothered as
long as there's no return to online
classes
it would be a shame after we've started
to relax and gain confidence in this
situation to have the feeling that
that's all going to be taken away again
if they bring back masks or testings
that's okay obviously it's simpler
without what would be good is if we
could at least stay in school
one thing seems clear there are no plans
to close schools again
but if infections soar there could be a
move to reduce class sizes with some of
the students watching online from home
teachers here don't relish that Prospect
but say it would be doable
taken and there's no way around it
we're equipped with various digital
platforms we've bought more iPads and
laptops and we're getting more training
for our teaching stuff so that they're
up to date with things
we have two years of experience now we
know we can divide the children into
groups and that makes things more
relaxed
what's generating more debates among
colleagues at the moment is the energy
crisis which will be a double whammy
coming together with the covid crisis
this autumn
it's yet another challenge for schools
particularly because of the need to have
plenty of fresh air
many classrooms now have aerosol filters
but they're not sufficient on their own
schools are still required to ventilate
classrooms regularly which makes it more
difficult to save energy
is
the Dilemma for us is that we're
supposed to ventilate as much as
possible but I'm also supposed to keep
the room temperature at a comfortable
level which means heating more unless
you have great equipment that heats the
fresh air coming in you have to turn up
the heating more to keep the room
temperature stable in Winter imagine we
don't have a solution for this dilemma
there's no strategy for how we're going
to deal with it I guess we'll just have
to try and find a happy medium
[Music]
but some classrooms could get a little
chilly this winter at least that's what
many parents fear
the school's parent representative is
calling for a pragmatic approach
unseen the children can wear warmer
clothes you can try to ventilate why the
children are outside unable to move
around to keep warm Etc but of course
some parents are worried their child can
get sick because the classrooms won't be
ventilated as much they fear the
children will pay the price there's been
some quite inflammatory comments because
people are worried
foreign
the children could be facing another
strenuous winter
but then again maybe the adults are just
worrying too much
optimistic I'm pretty optimistic
and you need to be we wouldn't have
gotten through this time without a bit
of optimism of course you do worry about
it now and then but I want to focus on
the present that's what we learned
during the pandemic to enjoy what you
have in the Here and Now
no one knows how bad the predicted new
wave of infections will be in the fall
the Paola first school is prepared as
well as they can be under the current
conditions
developing and improving vaccines is
still keeping researchers busy could a
vaccine administered through the nose
help protect us all from another wave
China and India have just approved it
how's it supposed to work
[Music]
when you're given a standard set of
covid-19 vaccines via injection it kicks
off a response in the cells nearby
causing your immune system to begin
producing antibodies other parts of your
body soon begin churning out protective
cells called memory T cells and B cells
creating what's known as systemic
immunity this means protection against
the virus is spread throughout the
body's systems initial exposure to SARS
cov2 however happens in a specific place
the upper respiratory tract this is
where the virus invades but it can take
time for the protective cells and
antibodies to reach here
one potential way to amp up the response
is to apply vaccines via a spray
directly to the area where respiratory
bugs get into the body creating more
localized protection where it's needed
most
kind of like putting guards at the front
door of a house to fend off Intruders
rather than in the Attic or the basement
this is called mucosal immunity because
it's created in the membranes exposed
directly to the outside world
the goal is to make it impossible for
the coronavirus to gain a foothold
other advantages that nasal sprays have
over injections include not having to
train personnel as intensely to apply
them and of course they take needles out
of the process entirely nobody likes
those
[Music]
many nasal vaccine candidates are
currently in clinical trials and a few
have now been authorized in some
countries including China India and Iran
because so many people have already been
vaccinated via injection the authorized
nasal vaccines are mostly aimed at
providing updates to protection by
kickstarting mucosal immunity this
supplements the underlying systemic
immunity provided by injections and
provides an extra layer of immune system
support right where it's needed most
nasally administered covid vaccines
still have to clear regulatory hurdles
in most countries but more of them will
one day likely see wider use because
they'll make getting regular boosters
also to other respiratory diseases are
simple and painless process
before we go let's hear a little more
from children from different parts of
the world telling us what it's like to
be back in school
thanks for joining us stay healthy and
we look forward to seeing you again next
week
was kind of difficult for me I had to
wake up at four
I told my used to wake up at any time I
want I get anything that I want
at school was difficult and I had to
catch up with books
that I used to relax
sit on my phone
Corona That's when this is when I locked
on group there's a good clubs but on the
North Bayside Club Industries
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I was used of being online that when I
when I came back at school
like I'd forgotten everything I
I had stopped revising my book so
it also declined my studies
foreign
I used to perform well but I'm no longer
performing well
I used to do I used to revised my books
but now I'm no longer revising my books
is
[Music]
we started catching up we started going
for Zoom classes
furthermore at the end of the semester
we found out that we were already having
our exams we did them online we
submitted and we are now moving and on
track
[Music]
um
foreign
foreign
[Music]